we all love it when Netflix drops an
exciting new original film but finding
older overlooked gems in their catalog
can be just as satisfying in that spirit
we'd like to inform you that Netflix
recently added one chronically
underrated Matthew McConaughey flick
from 2011 that you would be remiss not
to check out the Lincoln Lawyer is a
classic courtroom drama adapted from the
novel of the same name by popular
thriller writer Michael Connelly
Connelly is the king of pop boiler
fiction and his 2005 book transfers well
to the screen the film stars McConaughey
as a trial attorney named Mickey Haller
a character that will be familiar to
fans of Connolly's writing The Lincoln
Lawyer novel is the first of five in a
series featuring Haller that concluded
in 2013 with the publication of the gods
of guilt the film like the series has
nothing to do with the capital of
Nebraska nor the 16th President of the
United States instead the title refers
the howlers propensity for working out
of the back of a Lincoln Towncar instead
of a standard legal office McConaughey
has been raking in the commercial box
Hawking Lincoln automobiles for the
better part of a decade now so he likely
felt right at home in the role according
to Connolly cannon Michael Haller is the
paternal half-brother of hieronymus
Harry Bosch another popular character
who made the successful transition to
screen on the Amazon Prime original
series Bosch though Titus Welliver Smosh
does not appear in the Lincoln Lawyer
joining McConaughey in the Lincoln
Lawyer is a full cast of a list talent
including Marisa Tomei as howlers
ex-wife margaret Macpherson Bryan Philip
II is nightmare client Lewis Ross Brule
John Leguizamo as Val Valenzuela Michael
Pena as hey-zeus Martinez William H Macy
is Frank Levin and Bryan Cranston is
detective Langford the plot of the film
used pretty closely to its source
material Louis Roulet the son of a
wealthy Los Angeles businesswoman hires
Haller to defend him in a pending
assault case ever the champion of the
accused holler takes the job and soon
discovers that the details of the case
parallel one of his former cases that
ended poorly
as the Lincoln Lawyer dives deeper into
the details he realizes that these
parallels may be more than mere
coincidence a condition that places him
in an ethical bine rule a proves to be a
thoroughly detestable character the
playboy son of a Beverly Hills real
estate magnate rule a stands accused of
brutally assaulting Regina Campo a
prostitute rouler had contracted for
services rouler insists upon his
innocence
even can [ __ ] a convoluted story about
how he must have been set up after
Haller and his chief investigator Frank
Levin getting to the evidence however
they learned the truth of relays history
this guy's got a type Frank to learn the
rest of this complex narrative and
experience it's thrilling conclusion
you'll have to check it out for yourself
we won't spoil the action but we can
promise that the dramatic tension holds
until the very last spring and that both
critics and audiences agree that it's a
winner according to box office mojo The
Lincoln Lawyer earned 86 million dollars
worldwide against the forty million
dollar budget
that's hardly a buffo performance by
Hollywood standards especially when you
consider it barely squeaked over the
breakeven line at home with the domestic
box office total of 58 million dollars
it's reassuring that audiences are
finally discovering this film via
Netflix since the critical response at
the time of release was almost
universally positive sandra hall from
the sunday morning herald appreciated
the opportunity to see McConaughey
demonstrate a little range she wrote in
her three and a half star review it's
nice to see McConaughey getting
relatively serious instead of coasting
through yet another witless rom-com ed
Travis at Hollywood Jesus agreed with a
positive assessment writing viewers are
treated to a top-notch whodunit mixed
with a wonderful central character
played by an ever better Matthew
McConaughey and sprinkled with dashes of
street smarts and authenticity
debbie-lynn Alaia said behind the lens
really summed it up with her take
writing the verdict is in 12 Oh in favor
of the Lincoln Lawyer that pretty much
says it all if you're looking for a
tense courtroom thriller with a stellar
cast you could do a lot worse than the
Lincoln Lawyer check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]